vous êtes prêts pour l'interview sur la
bouche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on bon interview sans la bouche vous
connaissez max interview sans tabou y
connaissez
une interview peuvent pas répondre en
parlant donc ils vont être obligés de
mimer leurs réponses vous préférez
hitler ou staline
il ya un site internet qui s'est créée
pour demander votre retour sur comédie
vous personnellement vous préfériez
l'époque vous étiez sur comédie ou npa
avec nagui
npa avec nagui
là plutôt comédie
[Rires]
nagui vous trouvez commandant npa est ce
que ça le fait comme il dit lui
trop d'accord est-ce que vous rêvez je
fais comment la télé est-ce que vous
rêvez d'avoir une émission à vous
combien de temps vous pensé que j'allais
être encore ensemble les robins des bois
pendant combien d'années
si jean-paul si vous deviez signifier
votre attirance pour votre camarade
marina vous le feriez comment
et vous
oh
oui est
ce que vous trouvez que les robins des
bois sont drôles
[Musique]
et vous
et
si je m'en vais faire un gag vous feriez
quoi
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il mettait un peu
ce bleu